dieser gesunde ingw shot bringt euch
durch den
Winter und er ist viel günstiger als
gekauft ingw muss drin sein ansonsten
könnt ihr einfach reinmachen worauf ihr
Lust habt ich habe jetzt Zitrone orange
und Sellerie und ich fange mal an
bisschen klein zu schneiden je mehr
Ingwer ihr nehmt desto schärfer wird's
ingwa rein natürlich BIO inwa wir
Findern das sowieso später deshalb
müssen wir nicht groß irgendwie etwas
sauber schneiden oder so sondern einfach
mal machen celerie orange den Saft einer
Zitrone etwas Agavendicksaft und
Apfelsaft Deckel drauf ab geht's
so wenn es gut durchgemixt ist sehen wir
dass es auf jeden Fall relativ stückig
ist deshalb sieben wir es einmal
ab und fertig ist unser ingw shot die
könnt ihr entweder sofort trinken oder
ein paar Tage im Kühlschrank aufbewahren